[Musique]
ségo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok c'est parti
je
là on a regardé c'est stressant parce
que c'est c'est carrément le staff aussi
du festival fait mes élèves de mercredi
soir il travaille beaucoup sur un
festival aussi en gros le fait de
préparer un spectacle et d'un côté
préparée
le festival c'est très très compliqué
pour nous on essaye de voir votre parti
pour le concours juste extrait l'extrait
des voix de voir ce que ça donne ensuite
dès qu'on finira en phr à la corée dans
l'ensemble sept corps et là ok est ce
que j'aime ici c'est parce qu'on est
tous en famille on se connaît tous et
même quand il ya des niveaux bas on
essaye de se faire basse ou des quoi et
j'aime j'aime faire ma passion j'aime
danser tout ce que je peux dire ok on
essaye 5 ça si c'était beau boubou note
à aa à aa
si nous claque ça va j'ai toujours aimé
la danse parce que ça fait un truc dans
lequel ça là la base c'est un battement
dans lequel et du coup ça a fait bouger
dans tous les sens ok les gars du coup
on essaye de faire sur le son ok c'est
parti
et
[Musique]
il
ok il manque un peu d'énergie et vous de
vous êtes trop vous êtes trop serré je
m'enrichis en danger refusent en riant
en énergie je m'enrichis la place à
l'euphorie jeu j'évacue mon stress en en
étant tout le temps une vraie pile
électrique en fait du coût des guidances
dexia sur la piste bas je suis moi même
un gros show politique je suis une
personne dans cette fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]